welcome to this video playing I'm nulla
um I'm not on em no love I don't know
it's always difficult Swedish probably I
haven't touched this opening for a long
ball oh I thought the bank oh ok but we
got them the the check benoni there's
also this idea with H for Bishop age 3
which is not bad oh but okay I don't
mind this classical approach yeah this
is always funny sometimes people play
that and it's just really blundering
upon I mean one needs to be honest about
this this is absolutely no compensation
it's like a bank-owned gambit where you
have the center closed and the bishop
only seven this is just just giving away
upon for no compensation okay so a form
and still need to be precise about
things how to do this b3 maybe mp3 maybe
maybe this is the most precise if I get
in rookie one Bishop f1 and then it's
basically over with any sort of claim
for compensation c4 i also have be for
Bishop takes Knight things and maybe
maybe maybe I should we should everyone
first I'm not sure about the move water
so rook be one yeah let's at least good
i don't want to waste them or spend so
much time here this is one of those
opening words where this extra
frustrating if you lose on time as is
why it is basically winning by mu 10
this is just just like that
yeah he has the only idea he has here's
some some how to play see form and
getting activity but it shouldn't really
work okay well then I can take with the
bishop as well to have Bishop c6 Bishop
c6 but okay I can also develop or let's
say coordinate the rest of the forces
yeah Bishop g5 is not not really not
really happening
yeah it's hard to not play that at some
point but here I can also go before
controlling c5 now you cannot take on a
fort's protected also by the b5 bishop
and my next move will just be a five I
think a five and Bishop c6f5 is just
trapping this night where's this night
going black resigns yeah it's really not
much to say b5 is just a blunder you
just take it and when the B win the game
unless your blunder of peace or
something white white is just a pawn up
yeah it's simply compared to to to the
bank oh I mean just compare this you
have the bishop on g7 reeking I mean
down the border big big piece on g7 and
here it is on e 7 with a close center
and the only thing that white needs to
do is make sure he's not blundering the
porn back and I only needed some this is
basically giving up to take only five
but black really is totally busted
before plus six feet honeycomb
evaluation very difficult to not lose
any of those pieces you know it's a gas
is just totally totally unplayable
opening black young black short term
should play something like like castles
here it's funny that stockfish only
gives us at 0.34 why this is pretty much
a joke but black black shot just casts
on here and play play normally this is
not one of the greatest openings for
black but it is definitely something
that you can
complain okay thanks for watching